the awards for art direction to present  them the star of Robinson Crusoe Danna  Herlihy and a girl who gave one of the  great performances of the year miss Jan  sterling for black and white art  direction and set decoration the winner  in New York the winner is on the  waterfront Richard day  Thank You Holly  so our color art decoration and art  direction and set decoration the winners  are the winner is 20,000 Leagues Under  the Sea  John Muir  and sex decoration a meal Puri  congratulations gentlemen  Robinson I just want to ask you one  question before you go how does it feel  being cast away on a desert island that  was Green all alone for 60 minutes yeah  well I'm a different problem Bob I was  there on a plane and the high and the  mighty with 60 other actors all members  of the Screen Actors Guild man it must  have looked like Friday night at  Schwab's drugstore do you think and  dance thank you very much